We're at the end of Yoreh Deah Siman
Kuf-Tet-Vav. We did yesterday the first half of
seif gimmel, discussing chemas Akum, Goyishe butter. So
we discussed yesterday that there are four opinions.
The Rambam brings down two opinions from the
Geonim. Some Geonim say it's muttar, it's not
included in milk, it's not included in cheese,
muttar. Another opinion said no, the gezeirah against
cheese applies to butter as well, it's assur.
The Rosh said really me'ikar hadin it's muttar,
but the minhag is that it's assur. And
the Rambam had some sort of p'shara shita,
there's a discussion exactly how to understand the
Rambam, and that is that you should cook
the butter, thereby burning out any possible non-kosher
milk that could have possibly been there. Fine.
So the topic now, we're in the middle
of the Rama. Seif for cooking that? That's
the Rambam. So now we're in the Rama.
We did the first two lines of the
Rama yesterday. Now the Rama is going to
discuss the concept of, based on what the
Mechaber basically told us, that there's different minhagim.
So what happens when you go from place
to place? So there's a perek in Pesachim,
fourth perek of Pesachim called Makom She'nahagu, which
discusses different minhagim in different places, and the
Mishna also tells us what happens when you
go from place to place. So to fully
appreciate what's going on over here, we have
to look at the sugya in Pesachim. So
the first Mishna in the fourth perek of
Pesachim on daf nun amud aleph, there the
topic is where the minhag, there were different
minhagim about doing melacha erev Pesach in the
morning. Everyone holds erev Pesach in the afternoon
not to do melacha, that's the time of
the korban Pesach, it's already a type of
Yom Tov, has dinim sort of like Chol
HaMoed, which is again not exactly our topic.
And then the Mishna says that there's different
minhagim, some have a minhag not to do
melacha erev Pesach in the morning, and some
a minhag erev Pesach that they do do
melacha, different minhagim. So then the Mishna says,
what if you go from place to place?
A very famous Mishna. Haholech mimakom she'osin lemakom
she'ein osin, if you go from one place
to the other, o mimakom she'ein osin lemakom
she'osin, I live in a place where we
don't do melacha, I go to a place
where we do melacha, or vice versa, says
the Mishna, nosin alav chumrei makom sheyatza misham
vechumrei makom shehalach lesham. So he takes on
the chumros of both places. Now, that's assuming
that he's going to be going back to
his original place. If you move from place
to place, so you take on the new
minhagim of your new place. But if you
plan on going back, so then you have
the chumros of both places, whichever place is
machmir either place, you take upon yourself the
chumros of both places. Okay. Then the Mishna
says, ve'al yishaneh adam
mipnei hamachlokes. Now, when you're in a place
where they're doing things differently than you're accustomed
to doing, let's say they're lenient, but I'm
not allowed to be lenient, I have to
be strict because I come from a place
where they're strict, so then I'm not allowed
in front of other people to do things
differently than is common practice in this place,
because that would lead to fighting, that would
lead to machlokes. Now, the two halves of
this Mishna don't always fit together, because I
have to be strict, but over here they're
not strict. So if it's clear, if it's
noticeable that I'm being strict and they're not
being strict, so I'm taking on the stringency
of the other place, but then I'm doing
something different than is common in the place
to which I've come. So the Gemara asks
this question on daf nun aleph amud beis,
it discusses it and it's some sort of
balance. These halachos are found in Orach Chaim,
Hilchos Pesach, Hilchos Erev Pesach, Siman taf samech
ches seif daled, and here it says when
it goes head to head, accepting upon myself
the stringency of the place I left versus
doing things differently and causing machlokes, the main
opinion is not to cause machlokes. Now, if
I could do my stringency behind closed doors
and no one will know, that's what I
have to do. But if it's not possible
to do that and it goes head to
head, it's more important not to do things
differently in a place where the minhag is
to be lenient than to take upon myself
the stringency of the place that I left.
That's what the Mishna Berurah says over here,
taf samech ches seif daled, seif katan chaf
gimmel. It's discussed at length in seif katan
yud daled and seif katan chaf gimmel. The
other place where this is really relevant bazman
hazeh... is in Orach Chaim beginning of Hilchos
Yom Tov Siman Taf Tzadik Vav Hilchos Yom
Tov Sheini. I go to Chutz La'aretz for
Yom Tov, so there they keep two days.
I'm a one-day person. Or they come from
Chutz La'aretz to Eretz Yisrael keeping two days.
So there the minhag over here is to
keep one day, the minhag over there two
days. You go from place to place so
you have to take upon yourself the stringencies
of both places, but you can't do it
in a noticeable fashion because that could perhaps
lead to machlokes. Okay, that's not our topic,
but that is the background of what we're
going to learn right now. So let's take
a look now in the Rama at the
end of Kuf Tes Vav. Yud Daled Kuf
Tes Vav Seif Gimmel. We're in the second
line of the Rama. Okay, there's a little
Chaf Aleph by the which belongs to the
Biur HaGra. Says the Rama: V'im holech mimakom
she'ein ochlin osah. I live in a place
where we don't eat goiyishe butter. And I
go limakom she'ochlin osah. I go to the
place where they do eat goiyishe butter. Ochel
sham imahem. I'm allowed to eat with them
the goiyishe butter. Now the Shach points out
in Sif Katan Chaf Tes: Af al pi
shedato lachzor, even though I have full intentions
to go back to my strict place where
they don't eat the butter, I'm still allowed
to eat with them. Why? We're going to
see in a minute why. This is again
against the rule. The chemas akum according to
the first mahalach in the Rama is against
everything we just said about going from place
to place. We just said we go from
place to place you have to take upon
yourself the stringencies of both places. When it
comes to butter, says the Rama, that's not
the case. I come from a place that's
strict, I go to a place that's lenient,
I'm allowed to eat with them. Says the
Shach again, af al pi shedato lachzor, even
though I'm planning on going back to my
place, I'm just a visitor, ochel imahem. Mah
she'ein kein bishar issur. That's not the case
by other issurim. By other issurim we said
you have to take on the stringency of
the place from where you've come. This is
an exception. The question is why. So the
Taz brings down two opinions. Look in the
Taz Sif Katan Yud Gimmel. Says the Taz:
V'lo shayach kan nosnu lo chumrei makom shehalach
lisham. Here it's not relevant the rule we
just learned from Pesachim Perek Daled and from
Orach Chaim Siman Taf Samech Chet. Why? De'mah
she'ochlin osah bamakom hahu where they're lenient about
eating the goiyishe mishum desham osin osah behechsher
u'vilo chashash ba'olam. He says you know what
creates a minhag to make it assur and
a minhag to make it muttar? It's not
a machlokes in halacha. It's differences in how
they make the butter. And therefore, the place
where the minhag is to eat it is
because it's done in a—we'll see in a
minute the HaGra why this is so—they do
it in a pure way, there's no suspicion
whatsoever that there's any problem. And therefore, v'ilu
hayu osin kan kemahem hayu gam kein ochlin
osah. I come from a place that's strict.
But you know why they're strict? Because they
do it in a funny way. They do
it in a problematic way. They do it
in a questionable way. So that's why we're
machmir. But if I would know that my
place had the way of making butter like
your place, then my place would also be
lenient. So it's not really so tied to
the sugya in Pesachim. It's a metzius. How
do they make the butter? We make the
butter pure, no problem. You make the butter
complicated, you have problem. So it really depends
on how they make the butter. Ela she'hurgalu
rubam kan. So I come from a place
that's strict. Why are they strict? Because the
way they make the butter. Now the poskim
talk about it, it's hard to understand. They
took they they didn't have a lot of
milk accessible, they didn't have a good way
of making butter, so they would kind of
collect everybody's leftovers and it came from all
sorts of funny places. I don't know, it's
hard to understand what that means exactly, but
they were machmir because it came from funny
places. Kein kasav Issur V'heter. This is how
the Issur V'heter understands this halacha. V'lo kemo
shekasav baLevush. But the Issur V'heter is different
than the Levush. The Levush has a different
reason why the rule doesn't apply over here.
V'lo kemo shekasav baLevush al zeh lefi shehu
issur kal. The Levush says it's a low-grade
issur. Since it's a low-grade issur, the rule
of Pesachim doesn't apply. So the Taz and
Issur V'heter, they don't like that. De'chol sheyesh
issur mah li kal mah li chamur. What
does it mean? If the minhag is assur,
assur. Who cares? It's a high-grade issur, low-grade
issur. He says that shouldn't make a difference.
So they knock off the Levush very stark.
Issur V'heter doesn't agree with the Levush, the
Taz doesn't agree with the Levush, and it's
a din in metzius. Look at the Biur
HaGra Sif Katan Chaf Aleph. The Biur HaGra
Sif Katan Chaf Aleph. He skips to the
last two lines. Kemo shekasav Maharil Siman Lamed
Hei. The very end of the Biur HaGra
Sif Katan Chaf Aleph. De-makom she-nohagin heter, the
place where the Minhag is that it's Muttar
to eat the Goyishe butter, it's right on
the Rama we just did. De-makom she-nohagin heter,
lefi she-hu eretz harim, because it's a place
that's very mountainous u-mekom mir'eh, there's lots of
grazing place for the cows ve-cholvin harbeh yachad,
and they milk tons of cows over there
ve-ein lachush sham, and therefore you don't have
to worry that they went door to door
picking up people's straggling leftover dairy products that
could come from all sorts of funny places.
That's why the Minhag over here was to
be lenient because we know where it came
from. There was no chashash ba-olam. That's Lashon
Ha-Issur ve-Hetter quoted in the Taz. Okay, that's
part one of the Rama, or whatever, part
one for today. Part two. Aval, says the
Rama, aval assur le-havi imo. You're not allowed
to take the butter with you mimakom she-ochlim
oso from a place where we eat it
lemakom she-ein ochlim oso to a place where
they don't eat it ve-le-ochlo bimakom she-nohagin bo
issur. I live in a place where the
butter we eat the butter. You live in
a place where you don't eat the butter.
I can't take my butter to your community
and eat it there unless im lo she-yesh
bah heker unless there's something recognizable about the
butter she-hi mimkomos ha-muttarim that it came from
my place as opposed to your place. It
has to be something special. Your butter is
all I don't know in a blue wrapper,
our butter's all in a red wrapper, whatever.
So if it's something recognizable, then it's going
to be okay. What's the problem in bringing
it over? The Aruch HaShulchan says the problem
is Maris Ayin, and therefore if there's a
heker, it's going to be okay. The sugya
of heker and Maris Ayin is discussed at
length in Yoreh Deah siman pey-zayin se'if gimmel
in the Rama, ayin sham for homework. The
Gra over here says that it's not a
din in he doesn't call he doesn't talk
about Maris Ayin. He says it's a din
from the Mishnah: don't do things differently mipnei
ha-machlokas. It's going to be machlokas. I'm going
to come to your place, you're going to
see me eating butter. What are you doing?
We don't eat that stuff over here. Shake
it! Right, it's going to cause machlokas. But
once there's a heker, it's not going to
be a problem of machlokas. Look at the
Biur HaGra se'if katan chaf-bais: Aval assur, k'mo
she-kasav perek daled de-Pesachim, that's the Mishnah, mipnei
shinui ha-machlokas. If I do things differently, I
go to your place and I do things
differently than you're doing it, I do it
the way we do it back in my
place, that's going to cause machlokas. Mah she-ein
kein be-yesh bo heker, unless there's a heker.
Your blue your butter has a blue wrapper,
my butter has a red wrapper, then it's
very clear that my butter didn't come from
your place, it came from my community, and
then there won't be machlokas. Skip the next
few words: Alma de-chol ke-hai gavna mishum machlokas.
So when there's a heker and it's recognizable,
there's no problem of doing things differently mipnei
ha-machlokas because it's known that it's my butter
didn't come from your community,
it came from my community. The only issue
still remains, says the Gra, rak mishum chumrei
ha-makom. I'm still supposed to keep the stringencies
of the new place. Ve-kan leisa mishum chumrei
ha-makom. But when it comes to the issur
or the minhag of chemas akum, we there's
it's not relevant, the chumros of the different
places either, right, like we just saw in
the Taz. We know that's not relevant. And
therefore if my butter is recognizable, I can
take it from my place where we eat
it to your place where you don't eat
it. It's recognizable, it's not going to be
a problem. If it's not recognizable, I can't
bring it. Again, I'm going to read that
line again: Aval assur le-havi imo, I can't
bring it with me, ve-le-ochlo bimakom she-nohagin bo
issur, eat it in a place where the
minhag is that it's assur, im lo she-yesh
bah heker unless it's recognizable she-hi mimkomos ha-muttarim
unless it's recognizable that it came from a
kosher place because whatever we have a different
color wrapper. Next part of the Rama: ve-holech
mimakom she-nahagu vo hetter lemakom she-nahagu sham issur.
If I go from my place where we
eat it to your place where you don't
eat it: assur le-ochlo sham. So if I
go from my place where we eat it
to your place, then I'm not allowed to
eat it in your place. Okay. The Gra
here again in se'if katan chaf-gimmel: Ke-nizkar le'il
mipnei ha-machlokas, keivan she-ochel chemah shelahem. So that's
going to cause machlokas. I'm not clear the
Gra is going with this mahalach that of
the Taz, although that's what he said before,
but okay. Ve-atah, now, the last thing, now
the Rama brings in a ve-yesh omrim and
turns everything upside down. Says the Rama: Ve-yesh
omrim de-hu ha-din im huva mimakom hetter lemakom
issur. Some say it's the same thing. If
I take
it from my place is muttar, I bring
it to your place is assur, nami assurah,
it's also going to be assurah, afilu yesh
bah heker, even if it's a different wrapper.
That which we said before, it's a different
wrapper, it's recognizable that it came from a
different place, we said it's *muttar*. Now the
second opinion, it's a *stam* and a *yesh
omrim* in the *Rama*, but the *Rama* concludes
*vehachi noheg*, the *minhag* is like this *yesh
omrim*, that even though it has a wrapper,
and even though it's recognizable it came from
a different place, it's still gonna be *assur*.
So the *Sefer Chelkat Binyamin* wants to explain
that this, and it sort of looks like
this *Rabbi Akiva Eger*, we're not gonna look
at *Rabbi Akiva Eger* inside, but you can
look at *Rabbi Akiva Eger* for homework, *seif
katan alef*. The *Chelkat Binyamin* understands that this
*yesh omrim* disagrees with everything we just said
about the *Rama*. And it's not that in
this place they make it in a problematic
way and this place they make it in
a *kosher* way, says the *Chelkat Binyamin* what's
going on over here is everyone makes it
the same. But we know there's a *machloket*,
like the *Rambam* says, some *Geonim* say *muttar*,
some *Geonim* say *assur*. So some places they
hold it's *muttar* and some places they hold
it's *assur*. It's a *machloket*, there's different *minhagim*.
And therefore, it is relevant to the whole
*sugya* that we discussed in *Pesachim* on *daf
nun amud alef*. The whole *sugya* *makom shenahagu*.
And it's the same *sugya* as appears in
*Orach Chaim taf-samech-chet*, and the same *sugya* that
appears in *taf-tzadi-vav*. Okay, it's the same thing.
And therefore, even though it's recognizable, it's still
gonna be *assur* because you're in a place
that it's *assur*, and you have to accept
upon yourself the stringencies of the place to
which you've come. However, however, however. This that
I have to accept upon myself the stringencies
of the place that I come is only
in public. It's only in front of other
people. But in the privacy of my own
home, says the *Chelkat Binyamin*, I can eat
the butter. I can eat on butter. You
give me a room, I have a *yechida*,
I am my own little room, my own
little kitchenette, I can eat the butter as
long as nobody sees. Even though I'm in
a place where it's *assur*, since I come
from a place where it's *muttar*, I'm planning
on going back to my place where it's
*muttar*, I'm allowed to eat it privately. Publicly
I can't eat it even though it has
a different label and even though it's a
different wrapper and even though it's clear it
didn't come from this place. Now, this rule
that we're doing something different, you're not allowed
to do publicly, you are allowed to do
privately, does not apply to *melacha*. Okay? The
two cases, the case of doing *melacha* on
*erev Pesach* in the morning, there you're not
allowed to do *melacha* at all. We don't
say in the privacy of your own home
you can do *melacha*, because *melacha* is understood
to be something, this is *Tosafot* on the
top of *daf nun-bet amud alef* in *Pesachim*.
*melacha* is something that by definition is considered
public. Even as private as you want to
make it, *melacha* is considered public, people are
gonna find out. So butter, no one's gonna
know if I eat the butter. Butter I
can eat in the privacy of my own
home even if I'm in a place where
the *minhag* is that it's *assur*. But *melacha*
I can't do even in the privacy of
my own home because it's gonna become known,
everything private when it comes to *melacha* is
like public. Now this is extremely relevant because
you have a *ben Eretz Yisrael* who goes
to, or you have a *ben Eretz Yisrael*,
he keeps one day *Yom Tov*. He goes
to *Chutz la'Aretz* for *Yom Tov*. So now
the second day of *Yom Tov*. So according
to what we said, he should really be
allowed to do *melacha*. He can't do *melacha*
in public because of *machloket*, but really he
could do *melacha* in the privacy of his
own home. But *melacha* is an exception to
the rule. And therefore he can't do *melacha*
even in the privacy of his own home.
Now the truth is, this is a *machloket
Magen Avraham veha-Taz*. The *Taz* is lenient, the
*Magen Avraham* is strict, the *Mishnah Berurah* comes
out *lechumra*. On the last page in *Rav
Nebenzahl's* *Sefer Yerushalayim Bemodeha* on *Shavuot*, on the
very last page, maybe there's a new edition
that changed things, there's a question here, question
*tet-zayin*, and here they imply that you're allowed
to do *melacha betzina*. They don't say it
straight out, they imply *ben Eretz Yisrael beChutz
la'Aretz* who's doing *melacha betzina*, if they ask
him, he shouldn't, whatever, he should whatever he
should say. What do you mean he's doing
*melacha betzina*? It's not allowed! So I brought
this to *Rav Nebenzahl*. I said, don't we
*pasken* like the *Magen Avraham*, the *Mishnah Berurah*?
Why is he doing *melacha betzina*? And *Rav
Nebenzahl* said *ta'ut*, it's a mistake. When a
*ben Eretz Yisrael* goes to *Chutz la'Aretz*, he's
not allowed to do *melacha* on *Yom Tov
Sheni* even in the privacy of his own
home. It's considered, private *melacha* by definition is
public. Private consumption of butter is private and
that's okay. Private *melacha* by definition is halachically
considered public and it is forbidden even in
the privacy of your own home. That concludes
*Siman kof-tet-vav* in *Yoreh Deah*. *Chemdat*